nous avons pour la protection incendie
pris un certain nombre de mesures
d'abord nous avons réduit la présence de
l'électricité dans les combles parmi les
hypothèses de l'incendie il y a celui
d'un court-circuit dans dans les combles
nous avons nous allons mettre en place
un système de détection de fumée par
aspiration nous allons mettre dans les
combes ce qui n'existait pas avant des
parois coupe-feu
nous allons redimensionner les colonnes
sèches alimentant les combles nous
allons enfin nous allons va être
installé c'est pas c'est pas
l'établissement public ça bien sûr c'est
les parties prenant de la cathédrale un
nouveau PC sécurité incendie qui sera
armé 24 heures sur 24 vous avez le droit
de vous interroger évidemment sur le
fait que ça aurait pu être fait avant
évidemment nous avons
avoir des pièces d'accès sécurisées à
proximité des charpentes pour les
pompiers en intervention
nous allons avoir une augmentation
Parrot Paris de l'alimentation en eau de
l'île de la Cité et surtout nous allons
installer un dispositif de brumisation
en vue de voilà un dispositif de
brumisation automatique sur la charpente
rénovée vous voyez nous avons pris cette
affaire à bras le corps et voilà les
mesures qui vont être mises en œuvre
pour accompagner le choix du chêne pour
reconstruire la charpente